this is James panera he's managing
editor of New Criterion also writes for
City Journal and Wall Street Journal and
you've written a great piece about the
influence of American punk rock on
artists specifically China's AI weiwei
and Russia's punk trio [ __ ] riot right
so tell me how has American punk rock
influence these guys okay well let me
start off by saying I'm someone who's
generally skeptical of political art and
that's because political art tends to be
used by regimes as a way to oppress
their people it seduces go back to the
French Revolution you look at the desk
of Marat yes the Mirage which is a
fantastic pain exactly but it was used
by the Jacobin stewin you know inside
the terror in the case recently of AI
weiwei and [ __ ] riot what's interesting
to me is you have art being used in a
very different way it's political but
it's being used against propaganda it's
being used as the conscience of reform
and it's having in my opinion a real
effect so I asked myself what is it that
differentiate this new form the new
political art as i call it more
effective political arm what
differentiates it and i realize that
they have a punk influence instead of
let's say having an artist in the early
20th century living in paris and being
influenced by Marx you have here artists
too unless they coming to New York in
the case of AI weiwei and being
influenced by CBGB's now I way way
during that period really absorb the
whole ethos of the neighborhood not just
in punk music but the kind of punk
mentality he also spent that time
photographing extensively everything
going on he took I think something like
10,000 photographs and through those
photographs going to CBGB's kind of
absorbing the spirit of the neighborhood
he really I think took in a kind of a
punk aesthetic yeah if you will and one
thing it particularly he did was
photographed the top and square park
riots in 1988 now in that case the
police were imposing a curfew were
clearing the park in my opinion
justifiably of a kind of Occupy Wall
Street type movement yet they
overreacted they in fact incited a riot
and that's been that was proven later I
way they took some very important
photographs of that event so we saw
samples of the heavy-handed use of the
state and he saw how art could actually
push against that and reveal that
because of his father's background in
China and being a political prisoner did
he have a different reaction than an
American born artist what was happening
in Tompkins Square Park well you know
it's a sad case because I Weiwei's
father was a very famous poet he was a
follower of Mao and he like many
intellectuals and mouths china fell on
the wrong side of mao in the end and was
sent to a labor camp where I way was
born and raised so I think I weiwei came
out very skeptical of kind of idealistic
movements and I think that's one thing
that punk has punk has a healthy
skepticism of the state it's not
idealistic it's more willing to
criticize I think it's more pragmatic it
also has an energy I think to kind of
press that pragmatism out into the world
and broadcast it the Russian punk rock
trio [ __ ] riot they were also
influenced by punk rock they were
performing in an orthodox church and
were thrown in jail for it plus your
ride really comes out of a performance
art group in Russia and they've kind of
taken on the idioms of a punk rock band
and in this case to particularly
borrowing from the punk rock of the
Pacific Northwest the kind of girl right
Bikini Kill stop what they've done is
they've used kind of the punk rock
aesthetic to go into unorthodox places
or very Orthodox places in this case the
church in in Moscow to draw attention to
what they see as the corruption of the
church the thug Aqua sea of Putin now
okay they did a little misdemeanor
offense we might admit that they however
went on trial and if show trials people
people call it and they were sentenced
to two years hard labor and that's to
pretty extreme verdict clearly a
politically motivated what was
remarkable about this case is that the
images of them in that courtroom behind
those glass three beautiful women up
against these male thugs in the Putin
regime that was the political image
making working I think against an author
authoritarian state the one combining
factor punk rock is the
anti-authoritarian streak correct i
would say in this case yes and also good
music james monroe thanks so much thank
you reasontv in the park I'm Kennedy